What in the world is Kwanzaa?
Basically, Kwanzaa is a holiday that salutes and recognizes...
...the cultural roots of people of African descent.
But what does the word "Kwanzaa" mean?
Kwanzaa? Kwanzaa means the "first fruits of the harvest" and the language of Kiswahili,...
...which is spoken in certain parts of Africa.
When do you celebrate Kwanzaa?
Kwanzaa is celebrated from December 26 to January 1st.
Well, where does Kwanzaa come from?
The roots of Kwanzaa come from certain African harvest celebrations.
In 1966, Dr. Maulana Karenga developed Kwanzaa from the perspective...
...of Africans in America and all around the world.
Is Kwanzaa a religious celebration?
Kwanzaa is not religious or political; it's cultural.
What I wanna know is, can you give gifts on Kwanzaa?
Yeah, you can give gifts during Kwanzaa, but the point is, don't go broke doing it.
The gifts of the Swahili should be something...
...practical and meaningful like a book or something that you or another African has made.
Okay, I get it. I get it. Kwanzaa is just a black version of Christmas, right?
No, no, no. Kwanzaa has nothing to do with Christmas.
It has meaning to us as a people; it's more like a cultural reaffirmation.